This is the room where we'll be discussing AI in cancer
care, and we're going to be talking through some practical applications in
transforming oncology. My name is Caroline Chung.
I'm a professor in radiation oncology and diagnostic imaging at MD Anderson Cancer
Center, co-director of the Institute for Data Science and Oncology,
and the chief data and analytics officer at MD Anderson.
And so we're really excited to have you all here.
For those of you in the room, please use the QR code if you
choose to use the Q&A option to actually ask your
questions, or you can use the live mics across the room, and
please use your mics when you ask to ask your questions as there are people
joining online as well. So
hopefully you're in the right room, and you're really excited to learn today.
We're really excited to talk about AI.
There's a lot of enthusiasm of using this very rapidly evolving
technology, and we're really starting to build
today on some of the practical pieces that are really exciting.
But I'm also hoping to show you some perspectives.
If you're working with AI and you're thinking about developing
and thinking about how you're going to develop these tools so that they can
actually be applied and utilized in your cancer research as well as
potentially deploying this out into the clinic, there are some
considerations to be made, and I'll be talking about that topic.
And then we'll be diving a little bit deeper into two really interesting
topics, looking at tissues and characterizing
tissues at a much deeper level and going through multilayer,
multiscalar types of resolution, as well as more of a
clinical example of utilizing genomics in the clinical trials and
clinical space. And so we'll be covering the spectrum.
Hopefully, there's a little bit for everybody, and hopefully you'll walk away with
some real concepts in terms of what you're doing in terms of the areas
that you're working on in utilizing AI,
applying AI models that may be out there in terms of open source, and what
to consider as you evaluate these, as well as if you're developing these
tools out, where you may want to
start your thought process so that you'll be more successful in actually
translating this into the clinic.
So I'll be talking about embracing cancer complexity.
We all know that cancer is very complex, and up until this point,
we've really started to simplify the data that we have around us
to ground ourselves and make sense of the data.
But with this emerging technology, we have the ability to
now really embrace the complexity of the data and AI and
keep that in context. And so
I'm going to be walking through some high-level overviews that will hopefully
ground you in terms of your thought processes as you walk through the
second and third presentations from our speakers.
So if we think about where we started and the expanding
opportunities to really adopt data-driven tools in medicine,
the history of medicine has really been that practice of medicine, and we still
call it the practice of medicine. And I liken that true
one-on-one patient interaction, kind of like looking at a patient
just like you're looking at the weather through a weather vane.
You're seeing that patient in the room in that moment.
They may be distressed, they may be in pain, and you can assess where they are in
that moment, but you don't really see the full picture.
And so if you think about evidence-based medicine, as we start to
transition to evidence-based medicine, if you take that weather analogy,
I liken meta-analyses and collections of meta-analyses to
the Farmer's Almanac. It's not to say that it's not useful.
Farmer's Almanac is very useful at predicting
recurring weather patterns, big changes, and yet it's
not going to provide us with the type of information that we may want for an
individual patient sitting in front of us.
And yet we have a lot of data that is now being collected as part of clinical
care. We've got all of the different omics.
We've got the clinical parameters.
We've got digital health data, wearable sensors, et cetera,
coming at us, and how we actually integrate this into a
true GPS-like weather map that is ever-changing
and able to anticipate if a hurricane is coming at you or a tornado is
coming at you or not, and what that probability is,
is really where we're trying to aspire to get to in
personalized medicine. But the challenge is that these
data types are coming in quite heterogeneously, and
we're still struggling with embracing that complexity of
when the
data is coming in, how it's coming in, how it's different.
And I would say that one of the things that I'm going to talk through is
when we're trying to solve these problems, simplifying down that data
rather than embracing that complexity
may bring simplified solutions. But to quote Albert
Einstein, if you had an hour to solve a problem, perhaps we should spend
55 minutes thinking about that problem, understanding the problem,
understanding that complexity, and then taking the five minutes to think
about the solution because you understand what you're trying to do.
So when we think about actually building out a model, and
we'll take some historical examples of supervised learning models and
translating this out into the real world, one of the challenges that we've
had is that historically, up until this point, we've had
data collection come in from various different sources,
and they could be from multiple hospitals, and the
data generally has been flattened, cleaned, curated, and
so even what we call real-world data is not necessarily
truly reflective of what is being generated and flowed in the real
world. The more work that you need to do to
get this real-world data coming from different
hospitals into a state where you can actually train your
model,
that gap is going to be the same gap you're going to
have when you're trying to deploy the model.
Because if you think about how much work it took to get your data
into a state where you could actually train and validate and test this model,
that's the same gap you're going to have to overcome when you're running
that model in the real world. So that's just oneStatement number
one that you need to think through.
So if you create a very complex model that's expecting
all these different data streams to come in, in completeness
every single time, it's going to be much harder for you to successfully
deploy that model later on because the
data's not going to come in every single time in that completeness.
And so really thinking through what is available consistently,
and that may depend on the question that you're asking,
the
clinical situation that you're trying to address.
And so in certain circumstances, you may want to have a very
complex model. In other circumstances, if you're thinking about deploying
at scale across multiple hospital systems, then you need
to start to think about what is readily available across all of those hospital
systems. Because at the end of the day,
what is deployed in the real world is going to reflect on what is actually being
captured in clinical care. And
at MD Anderson, we start to think about if we're going to use a
model, how is that going to change how we need to generate that data moving
forward? And so really thinking about data at the first mile.
And so
this is where the AI chasm that Eric Topol has mentioned back in
2018, that you can get a beautiful publication and
pilot that gets us very excited about the promise of what
could be the potential goal and potential
achievable using AI technology. And then there's a
big break and leap until we get to true implementation and
impact. But I would say that if you start to think through the context, if you
start to think about the gap of where that data was generated
and how much work you needed to do to clean it versus where you're actually
going to use it, this chasm starts to narrow and you will be able to
make that leap much faster.
And one of the pieces that you can bring forward is embracing the context
of the data. So think about the quality of that data, the
source of that data. Where did it come from? What was the journey?
Was it automated? Was a human involved? How much variability?
Was there a standard way to actually collect this data?
What sorts of biases are there? And the biases are not necessarily
only the demographic biases of a population, but
they could be technical biases, and I'll give you some examples in this
presentation. What is the uncertainty of that data?
How much confidence do you have? And this is true to
consider at your training stage, at your validation and test
stage, as well as in your implementation stage.
So you can't really isolate this as a continuum across the
board, and if you don't think about the implementation while you're doing your
training and validation, it's going to be very difficult to actually translate.
So let's consider imaging as well as tissue and fluid,
because I think we've got a mixed audience here.
If you think about a quantitative imaging workflow and how it can
actually facilitate
being able to understand uncertainty quantification and confidence in your
data.
If you're going to gather images, let's say you're looking at CT scans
or MRI scans, the acquisition of those
images depend on which scanners are these hospitals
using to actually image the patient.
It's going to depend on how that machine was calibrated and how it was
actually quality controlled. It's going to depend on the protocol, and
we know that there's many different protocols that many different
hospitals use. And so the
larger the number of different protocols, the more complexity there
is in the data that you're using to train this model.
And so if you flatten and assume that you're getting the same measurement,
you may not be, and this is where biases can get introduced.
If you think about not only the images that are acquired, if you
post-process these images differently, and there have been some recent
publications showing how many different ways a lung nodule can
appear with the same scan and post-processing
that scan differently, you're going to get the nodules looking in a
different shape, a different size.
Perhaps it's not even visible in certain circumstances that are very extreme.
And so this post-processing step can actually influence what you're
actually training your model on. The registration over
time. Many of us are interested in looking at changes of the tumor across
time, and if your registration is not anatomical,
you may not necessarily be looking at apples to apples.
When you look at the segmentation, if you're looking at manual segmentation,
there's interobserver variability, and depending on the
heterogeneity of the images, even if you use an automated tool,
you may not get consistent segmentation.
And this all influences the quantitative measurement that you may be
extracting to relate to some outcome, whether it be survival or tumor
response. The same philosophy and same methods
apply when it comes to tissue. So the tissue and biofluid that's
being collected, how is it collected?
How much time did it spend at a certain temperature?
What are you doing to process this?
Is there harmonization across the analytic platforms
that you're actually using before you actually extract the quantitative measurement
that you're really interested in?
And in the genomic space, we've recognized this with batch effects
as one example. And so variability at any one of
these steps adds complexity to your model.
And the reason why this is helpful, and I wouldn't say necessarily
that it's a barrier, is that if you acknowledge that heterogeneity, you can
start to incorporate that in your model training.
Start to think about the heterogeneity in that data so you can
actually see how robust your model is going to be when you're actually going to
deploy broadly.Here's an example
in terms of data heterogeneity in terms of radiomics and
the quantitative imaging example.
So if you take one patient and most people think about this row at the
very top, that the images are acquired, and then
it's just processed, and you get these feature extractions.
Now, why did radiomics struggle to actually get deployed
broadly? Because what happened was, if you took a patient and they went
through the pink path versus the blue path, and then you've
got differences in image reconstruction, differences in post-processing,
differences in segmentation, you end up with 1,000 different potential
measurements, 1,000 different feature extractions coming out of
the same patient, depending on what path that they took.
And so if we don't account for this heterogeneity when we're
building our models and we're accounting and evaluating our
models, we may not actually be seeing true
biological signal, which is what we're all interested in, but really detecting the
technical noise rather than the biological signal.
This
is one extreme example, and if you think about clinical trials,
for instance, in the brain metastasis space, just even slice thickness
of an MRI can make a tumor be visible or invisible because
brain metastases can be very small.
And so we can have patients enrolled onto a trial, and they
may not have new brain metastases.
They just happen to get a scan that was sliced thinner, and we've detected a brain
metastasis. This could actually influence the outcome of that
trial because you're now getting patients who we think are responding to
treatment, and perhaps that tumor has been present and stable all
along, and it may not be a true response.
And so really thinking through the quantitative
methodology will actually help you decipher some of these
erroneous signals that are really a reflection of the technical noise.
And so to ground your insights with data in
context, there's a paper that I published in "Cancer Research" in
2021 talking about the fact that cancer needs a robust
metadata supply chain. So really thinking about all the descriptors
around the data, thinking about the context of that data, and
bringing that forward in your model considerations, and
considering that metadata layer in the model training,
validation, and implementation.
Thinking about data quality in context, that this does
not mean all of a sudden we need perfectly uniform data.
You actually could take heterogeneous data as long as you account for
that heterogeneity.
And this is because depending on the question you're trying to ask,
the data that's not useful for one question may be
useful in another. And so really thinking about that metadata will
actually help you select out the data that's most appropriate
for the question that you're trying to answer with your model as you're
developing it. It will help you select out the data sets that will be
most meaningful to you to actually address the question that you're
after. And this will account for the quality, the source, the bias,
and the uncertainty.
So I'm going to wrap up here to make sure that we have enough
time for questions and say that AI has great
promise to help us embrace that complexity of data in cancer
care, tackling medicine as a science of uncertainty and an
art of probability that's centered on the person rather than the
illness. We need to consider the context from
design all the way through to delivery of an AI model.
And the context includes the people, the data, the operational
processes, the digital environment, and the systems and regulations
that you may be facing, depending on if you're in early in research through to
clinical deployment.
Clearly defining the purpose of what your model is going to do
and the context in which you're going to use it will inform how much
tolerable uncertainty that you will be
accepting of, and then the metadata around it will actually help
you account for the uncertainty that you're dealing with.
Finally, whether it's the imaging chain or the
tissue chain, considering the entire chain of events from the
collection of the data through to the processing and the
analytics will help you bridge this development through to
translation and implementation.
And I have a couple other references here in case you're interested.
And so thank you very much, and I'm really excited to kick off the rest of the
session.
So we're going to take questions at the end so that we have some
flexibility and time. So next up, we have
Dennis Brooks,
who will be joining us, and he will be presenting-
And of course, I'm-
... on 3D mapping of tumors
... starting off my presentation with a complete show-off of
this three-year construction. A Coda
workflow I'm going to talk about today that allows us to really
address a rather fundamental question about precancerous
lesions in particular, but really a methodology
grounded in many series of AI tools that is
tumor-agnostic, tissue-agnostic,
and can address, as I said, new questions thanks
to an ability to image tissues in 3D and at single-cell
resolution. So,
it's called Coda. It stands for nothing.
It's just a cool word, so don't try to
project anything.
It's actually a classical music reference.
If you thought it was about coding, it's not.
But here's the challenge. We're trying to do something that's nominally
impossible. That is, to image very large
volumesAt very high spatial resolution.
And either you go for volume compromising on spatial
resolution, think of CT scan, MRI,
but then you compromise, you have a limited resolution, maybe a few millimeters
at best.
Or you go for very high resolution,
but then you're going to lose the context, the larger context of the cell
cluster, the organ, or even the whole organism you may be trying to image.
And so we want it here both ways. We'd like to be able to image at
least multi-centimeter cube of tissue at, as I said,
cellular, even subcellular resolution.
The second requirement we like to have is to leverage
all these new advances in spatial transcriptomics,
proteomics, metabolomics, and be able to readily
integrate those modalities, but now guided by this
CODA reconstruction I'm going to talk about.
So again, we can image a large volume.
Our solution is CODA.
We can label many components. Indeed, that reconstruction of
this rhesus macaque fetus I was taking for a spin is
157 different cell types, spatially
resolved. You cannot imagine doing this using spatial
transcriptomics or proteomics. We can integrate
all standard modalities, IHC, IHC, spatial
transcriptomics, Codex, et cetera,
leading to very highly quantifiable data sets.
Okay. So it looks very brute force.
You start with your tissue. Here is a fallopian tube.
I'll talk about the fallopian tube quite a bit.
It can be FFPE'd.
You're going to be serially sectioning it, staining it, scanning it,
and now you have a series of scan images we're going to be
manipulating. Okay?
The first step in this workflow that is, I think, part of the secret sauce,
it's not so secret, we've published all the ins and outs of how to do this,
but is the registration step. We're going to be reconstructing,
aligning these scan images, and that
task has to be done really, really well.
Think of a problem of alignment early
at the top of your scan of images, that error is going to
propagate to the rest of your stack of images.
So we need also, if we're trying to perfectly
align locally, say, two cross-section of a blood
vessels
or a nerve or islets of Langerhans,
you're going to compromise in losing the fact that maybe your blood vessels
has the shape of a banana. So we, for that reason, developed an
iterative global and local registration scheme
that solved that problem. If you have a banana, it's going to recognize a banana,
but nevertheless preserve this beautiful local registration of
subsequent H&E section in these stacks of
H&Es. We're going to be
annotating, segmenting,
rather painstakingly, at least that's what we used to do.
We don't do this anymore, but what I'm going to show is mostly this, where maybe
5%, maybe as low as 2% of the sections are going to
be
segmented manually. We're going to recognize
everything that an histologist or pathologist expert can
recognize in the tissue and in each level. Okay?
We're going to train an algorithm, a CNN.
These are pre-trained algorithm.
We just chopped off typically the last layer
with a very minimum tweaking, get
accuracies of a port of 97, 98% for each of the
tissue components of these tissue samples.
And then finally, we like to deconvolve the hematoxylin
and eosin channels, so as to detect individual
cells in the segment. Okay? So this is on the left,
unregistered sections. I'm going through the stacks of a human
pancreas and on the right, very smooth transitions, demonstrating
that we have really very high resolution, indeed submicron resolution
in our local and global registration of those sections.
Culminating in a reconstruction like this one.
It's a kind of piece of ham, so to speak, a ribeye, and removing
your H&Es and replacing them with blood vessels in
green, ducts in dark blue,
in red a precancerous lesion, the PANIMS for the human pancreas,
ductal submucosa,
the islets of Langerhans,
some fat in there,
acini,
single cell resolution. So close to a billion cells were
properly positioned and identified exhaustively.
Not one is missed in this reconstruction.
So other demonstration, this is a psoriatic skin.
I know you're a bunch of cancer researchers.
You have no idea of what I'm talking about, or maybe you do, and you don't care.
But I find this reconstruction really beautiful.
You have this beautiful porcupine blood vessel structure we
see
in the epidermis. We can reconstruct mouse
lungs and bronchioles, and you can detect, and I believe
this should be the new gold standard when you do mouse modeling, really tiny
mets,
cell clusters as small as just five or six. Okay.
And
now really that flex I was talking about, we're going to be mapping
whole organism at single cell resolution.
This is a rhesus macaque. We've done the turtle, the
alligator, human, et cetera. On the left is blood
vessels, on the right are nerves. And we discovered that
actually, blood vessel and nerve follow beautiful
scale-free fractal geometry across species and
across developmental stages. Okay.
So the first illustration of integration of CODA is going to be
how we're going to be
trying to enumeratePrecursor lesion in
the healthy and disease adjacent
samples of the human pancreas.
And we're going to be integrating genomics with this Coda workflow.
This is the work of Ashley Kemeny, who's now a faculty in pathology at Hopkins.
Again, how many precursor lesions in the healthy pancreas?
Well, it should be zero or something close to zero.
We believe that
because they're microscopic, because they're rare, 3D imaging becomes
critical.
But also, can we determine through sequencing if these
lesions, if they exist, of course, the answer is in the question,
you can have many lesions, if they actually grow independently or
interdependently of each other. Okay.
So again, I'm going through the stacks of sections, and I hope you appreciate
that we color-coded the cross-sections that a 2D assessment, a
single or couple of section, would completely
miss the ability to be able to tell which
precancerous lesion is which. These cross-sections may be very
octopus-like, and therefore-- Sorry, the lesion can be
octopus-like. And so,
in order to be able to enumerate them, you'll be able to tell if they're physically
distinct from one another. So here you have
10, 15 such lesions in the sample.
And again,
showing you what the morphology of this panning actually looks inside the human
pancreas. Okay. So you have, I'm afraid to
say, all of us, in your healthy pancreas, about 100 to
500 lesions. If you extrapolate to the multi-center
cube samples we've done. When it's disease lesions, it becomes a
much larger number, up to 1,000. Okay.
Really dramatic.
We're going to now use Coda maps in order to
extract samples which we're going to de-sequence.
We're going to try to answer the question if the mutational
profile of these physically separated lesions is the same of each
other, or maybe the adjacent tumor, or distinct from one another.
So, in particular, address if these lesions can
be multifocal. So again, these are color-coded lesions, and in
orange is the actual PDAC tumor.
So we're going to do extractions through laser capture
sequencing, and indeed, most of those
pannings have completely different point mutations.
And if they're large enough, they're going to be multifocal.
Actually, all large lesions will have
multifocality. And you'll see that
the point mutations-- I don't know how to do the--
One of those lesions is the same as the PDAC tumor in the
vicinity of it.
But again, a 2D section could never tell you how many you've
got and also if they're distinct from one another.
And this is another example where we actually had a bunch of
lesions that had a similar point mutation to the tumor.
Okay, cool. The next thing we're going to do is, in a way, a
similar questions, this time addressing the case of the ovarian
cancer. Ovarian cancer does not originate in ovaries.
Actually originate in the fallopian tube.
And a bit as a flex, we're going to map an entire fallopian tube. Okay.
Our presumption was that the current way by which you can
assess the presence or absence of lesions
is a so-called CE-FEM protocol. You're going to section 10 or 15,
typically in academic hospital,
this fallopian tube, and then using H&E and additional stains like
Ki67 and p53, determine the
presence of such lesions. Here, we're going to section this,
1,500, 2,000 sections, four micron each, and we're going to go to town
with this. So the current understanding, the Pravda line, if
you will,
it's a Soviet era reference I'm making here,
is that STIC lesions are extremely rare in healthy
women, that the STIC lesions mostly appear in post-menopausal women when they
do appear, and that when they do appear, rarely, is
only in the fimbriae, that part of the fallopian tube that wraps around ovaries.
It's wrong, wrong and wrong.
So here's
a fallopian tube. Most men in the room don't have a clue what a fallopian tube
looks like.
Not to worry, most women don't have a clue either. So it's okay.
But this is not a dragon. You may think it is. It's not.
It's a fallopian tube. What I, as a physicist, really love
is that it's actually a multichannel structure. It's like your nasal cavity.
Trying to understand how nature decided to generate these beautiful
multichannel structures is something we're trying to understand better.
Okay. As far as I know, this is the first ever human
organ mapped at single-cell resolution
ever.
So one thing you can do just with H&Es, what I didn't tell you is that
we skip
typically two out of three, four out of five H&E sections,
so as to do a genomic sequencing. That was the previous here
assessment. We're going to also use these intervening
slide we didn't touch yet for other modalities.
So this is an assessment of both ciliated
and secretory cells, something you can do readily out of H&Es.
And indeed, we confirm a known result is that in
pre-menopausal women, you have mostly ciliated as a way
to generate the ciliated-based motion of oocytes
and switching to a predominantly secretory
phenotype in post-menopausal women's fallopian tube.
All right. So here's the real way we're going to now assess the presence or absence
of precancerous lesions.
Mind you, these are samples obtained from a
transplantation center end bot. These are women who die of car accident,
suicide, who are not BRCA1, BRCA2.
They're perfectly healthy.No sign of a disease.
In the center here, I zoomed in on one of these H&E sections.
I'm going through the stacks of sections, and I'm alternating between H&E
and then an IHC stain for Ki-67 and P53.
So we have four or five criteria that makes a lesion a lesion.
That is, it has to be Ki-67 positive, P53
positive, the IHC. It has to have
L-shaped nuclei, and at least 12 cells have to be adjacent to one
another
to declare that a lesion is indeed a STIC lesion.
Okay? And here I'm going through this 3D
reconstructed fallopian tube, and again, showing very nice,
beautiful labyrinth-looking structure.
But here you can already sense that I'm painting yellow and
red these lesions. Okay?
Here is the best projection. This is a 63-year-old woman,
and you can see that, and that was the case for the seven fallopian tubes
that we assessed. They all contain STIC lesions.
These are, again, perfectly healthy women.
And they're all P53, either P53 positive or Ki-67
and P53 positive. They're either indolent or
progressive STIC lesions. Okay?
And not all women are ticking bombs.
It's simply that there's clearly a minuscule subset of these
lesions are going to actually progress into an actual tumor.
Here we demonstrating how we can, again, integrate other
modalities, spatial transcriptomics, spatial proteomics, and
metabolomics, but guide it by the CODA map, not
willy-nilly and hope for the best.
It's actually where the lesion is, and now we can do a deeper
assessment. Okay? This is, for instance, a Codex
map, and showing that actually these lesions have all the attributes of a
tumor, short of being invasive. They are
immunosuppressive.
They actually have loss of chromosome six and gain
of chromosome 22. Really just simply the same point mutation you
find in ovarian cancer tumors.
I'm going to skip this. I'm going to show you that
these intervening slides can be used to map individual immune cells,
as a demonstration here is a healthy duct in the pancreas.
On the left is one of these octopus-like panning
structures, and we can see this is a recently published paper.
We see we can map out individual leukocyte T cells and T regs.
The key
take home message for this part of the work is that a given lesion
will
be cold and hot. You tell me what you want to see, and I'll give it to you.
That is, if you do not do a 3D assessment of the local
inflammation, you can be completely misled in the level
of immune cell infiltrate in the vicinity of these lesions.
Same thing for tumors. So this notion of cold and hot tumors should be
really revisited, in my opinion. So what's next for CODA?
We have basically developed an agentic AI
system.
We can now replace these manual annotations with
automatic AI-based
automatic annotations, preserving this very high accuracy.
We can stain unstained sections. We can,
through AI, automatically register these different type of images.
We can use generative AI to interpolate those missing slides.
Remember, I'm missing three out of four, five out of six,
and on and on. Okay? So to just
point out one of those tools, this is InterpolAI.
Often in histological sections, you have defects like this one, but it's the
case of many other imaging modalities.
MRI you have, the patient can move in a machine, and all those
artifact, it turns out, like light sheet, you have photobleaching,
cryo-EM, again, you have tears in the tissue
sections,
can be completely fixed via generative AI.
And we actually had the ground truth and get Pearson
coefficients that are almost
unit.
So I'm going to stop here. This is a reconstruction.
This is what we start on the left, and then you have the full
high-resolution reconstructed
duct in this case. All right, so CODA is a 3D mapping
technique that is agnostic for organs, for species.
We've done many different type of species.
Disease, I've shown you, of course, quite of work on
cancer, but we've looked at autoimmune disease, we've looked at
psoriasis in particular, and can be integrated with
multiplex IF, multiplex Codex, et cetera.
I'm going to stop here and recognize my
wonderful colleagues, in particular Laura Wood and Ralph Huber,
Ashley Kimiec now is independent, and Peishan Wu, partner in crime
in this
development of CODA and its validations.
Thank you very much, Dennis. So like I said, we're going to leave the questions
till the end.
If you've had your QR code, please continue to add questions in the
Q&A, or you're welcome to use the mic at the end.
It's my pleasure to introduce Michael Berger from Memorial Sloan
Kettering, and
he'll be talking about sequencing to treatment, the role of AI in precision
oncology.
Thank you so much. I'm really excited to be here, and to all of you for
attending. I know it's so nice outside and we're happy that you're here with us
here.
So my name is Mike Berger. I'm at Memorial Sloan Kettering Cancer Center,
and I have the privilege of describing some of the ways
that we've begun to incorporate and think about incorporating AI
methods into our clinical genomics workflows.
So I want to first start by defining to you what I think of when I say
clinical genomics workflow.
And in precision oncology, it typically involves taking DNA from
the tumor and sometimes match normal cells or tissues from patients with
cancer, creating libraries that we can then select for genes of
interest, either with amplification or hybridization,
in panels, but could also be whole exome or whole genome
sequencing, where we would then sequence these samples to high
coverage to detect mutations, copy number alterations, rearrangements,
individual alterations that could then be annotated for their biological
significance, for their clinical significance, and use this information
to guide the treatment decisions for patients with cancer.
We've been doing this at Sloan Kettering now for about 13 years with
next-generation sequencing, for probably close to 20 or more
years with
other mutation profiling approaches.
But AI methods have now improved enough that there are
real opportunities to incorporate
into our workflows, either for efficiency or for more
accuracy or more sensitivity, particularly in the areas of variant
detection,
variant interpretation, and clinical decision support.
And I also want to highlight a few additional applications that can leverage
these clinical genomics
workflows beyond just mutation-guided treatment selection,
such as cancer type diagnosis, monitoring and early detection of
cancer using liquid biopsy approaches, and
developing models
using real-world data and evidence to predict outcomes.
So this is essentially the outline of this talk today.
So I'll go through each of these categories and highlight some ways that AI methods
and tools are making a difference.
So first, with detection of genomic alterations, current practice, at least
for us, still involves probabilistic base mutation callers.
So using the allele counts for mutant and
wild type alleles to detect mutations, as well as base qualities and mapping
qualities and strand bias,
to derive a probability
score that we could apply thresholds to and call mutations.
Copy number pipelines typically use coverage, sometimes with SNP allele
frequencies, and we've certainly used this to great effect
at Sloan Kettering. So just a quick word about our clinical sequencing test.
We've been running MSK-IMPACT as our tumor normal 500 gene
panel for patients with cancer for now about 13 years.
We use both tumor and normal to distinguish between
somatic mutations, germline variants, and clonal hematopoiesis
mutations. And so far, we've sequenced over 100,000 patients with this
test, over 140,000 tumors, and which this data set has allowed us,
with high precision, to identify the frequencies of mutations across different
types of cancers, not just even general cancer types, but more
granular subtypes as well. And we've been able to supplement these
alterations detected clinically with additional, more complex
features and signatures and mutation properties to further enrich
these data sets. And just as a quick mention, our largest public
release was just published earlier this month in "Cancer Cell," if you want to take
a deeper look.
Even within these conventional pipelines, there are significant opportunities
for AI. So using error modeling to identify artifacts
beyond the conventional thresholds that are used.
AI-assisted QC and variant review for greater efficiency, given that this is
a significant bottleneck in our ability
to turn around the volume of tests that we perform in a
rapid manner.
And then, especially for labs that do tumor-only sequencing without the match
normal,
applying AI methods to infer which of the variants detected in the
tumor are
specific to the tumor versus inherited germline variants or
clonal hematopoiesis mutations in infiltrating lymphocytes, or
in liquid biopsy assays,
mutations that are detected in cell-free DNA, which is particularly challenging
given that the primary component of cell-free DNA is derived from hematopoietic
cells. So here's one example of a tool.
This was published by AstraZeneca last year called MetaCH that performed
this last task of training on our MSK-IMPACT tumor match normal
data to infer in a liquid biopsy test whether a given variant was
likely to be somatic or associated with clonal hematopoiesis.
But the methods for calling mutations have also fundamentally changed.
So this is actually not even that new at this point.
There's a whole new class of mutation callers that can
learn patterns directly from the raw data and essentially turn mutation calling
into an image analysis and recognition problem.
So Deep Variant is one of the first of these methods, which
was actually now 10 years ago, shown to have
the highest performance in the 2016 PrecisionFDA Truth Challenge and
performed particularly well for difficult to map regions.
This was for germline variant calling, and I guess the way, in general, these
methods work is they can take the read pile-ups, turn it into an
image or other machine-readable representation, and then with convolutional neural
networks trained on large data sets with ground truth, predict the
likelihood that a given
read pile-up is representing a mutation.
So this was first used for germline variant detection, but more recently has
been adapted for somatic calling through methods like new somatic and
deep somatic.And the kind of
information that we try to infer from the data goes often beyond the
presence of individual alterations.
So there are certain mutational signatures or other
genomic features that can have importance both biologically
and clinically. And AI-based signature detection can be
used because it's optimally suited to learn complex high-dimensional patterns.
So, one example of this being microsatellite instability, many of you may
know this is a genomic signature that's highly predictive of response to
immunotherapy and can be detected based on variable length insertions and
deletions at microsatellite sites.
AI methods can now use that integrated with somatic variants,
insertions, deletions, and sequence contexts.
And I'm showing here one example of a tool called myMSI that was developed by
colleagues at Sloan Kettering, that we've begun to perform
alongside our conventional method, MSI Sensor.
And it's actually shown to have better performance and result in fewer
indeterminate cases where we're unable to derive a result.
Another example being homologous recombination deficiency.
This is a signature representing a different type of DNA
repair defect that is often detected through genomic
scars, like widespread loss of heterozygosity and telomeric allele counterbalance
and state transitions in the genome.
But also can leverage additional patterns through single nucleotide variants,
indels, and structural variants.
And I'm showing here an example called Sigma, developed by Peter Park's group at
Harvard Medical School that can actually infer,
and adapt signatures based on larger whole genome and exome data,
down to smaller numbers of mutations inferred in panels.
So these are important tools that have immediate clinical
potential to inform treatment decisions.
So then once we've detected alterations, I'm reverting back now to
individual genomic alterations like mutations.
We want to ask, "Well, which of the mutations that we detected are likely
functional?" And this currently relies on databases,
population frequency, a little different for somatic and germline.
So for somatic mutation, we use evidence of recurrence across different tumors as
an indicator of selective pressures that suggest that the mutation is
functionally important.
For germline variants, usually common variants can be recognized as
likely benign or of minimal significance.
But also epidemiological studies, family studies, functional studies, any
information that we can leverage.
There are a number of databases now of both somatic mutations and germline
variants that help us infer whether a new variant that we detect in a given
patient is likely functional.
And there have also been a number of guidelines published for how to
actually interpret a given somatic or a given germline
variant, usually based on rules of what kind of evidence would
qualify
to
call a mutation as pathogenic or not.
And the framework is similar but slightly different between germline and
somatic mutations. For germline, there's a five-tiered system that goes
from benign and likely benign to pathogenic or likely pathogenic, meaning that
that variant is associated with the onset or incidence of cancer.
And for somatic mutations, typically we call it benign or likely benign or
oncogenic or likely oncogenic, suggesting that that mutation is important
for the ongoing tumor genesis progression of cancer.
And there have been methods
trained on these large databases of known functional
variants that have been used to develop, in these
cases, largely random forest models predicting the functional
consequences of both somatic and germline variants.
And I'm showing a number of examples here, and some of you
may be very familiar with these.
But we've sort of entered a new era of deep learning where neural
networks can be assembled, leveraging some of this information, as
well as, in the case of AlphaMisSense,
which is based on AlphaFold,
protein structural information along with evolutionary conservation.
So AlphaMisSense a few years ago was released by Google
DeepMind as a way to predict
the pathogenicity of missense variants.
Splice AI is a tool from Illumina that can infer splicing
from pre-mRNA sequence and identify splice junctions
and therefore identify the likely consequences of splicing on individual
missense mutations.
And then, most recently, AlphaGenome, kind of a follow-on to
AlphaMisSense, was released by Google DeepMind earlier this year, that
can take large stretches of non-coding sequence and infer at base pair
resolution the likelihood of changes that impact chromosomal accessibility,
transcription factor binding, splicing, expression, and many other
genomic tracks. So this is all happening very quickly, but tools that we
can take full advantage of.
All right. So now,
the next step beyond inferring the likely functional significance of mutation is
determining whether there are clinical implications for a patient's treatment when
we see those mutations. What's the clinical actionability of the mutations that we
find? And this, I think, still relies largely on
expert-curated clinical knowledge bases.
So a number listed here, featuring OncoKB, which is
a somatic knowledge base that was developed by a number
of
scientists and clinicians at Memorial Sloan Kettering Cancer Center,
where at this point over 1,000 genes have been annotated, not
just at the gene level, but at the variant level in the cancer type context
for the clinical significance of individual variants that we detect in our
MSK-IMPACT tests. And there's a very specific protocol
that's followed and specific tiering criteria from
FDA-approved treatments to investigational
therapies in preclinical data.
And even within this framework, there's important opportunities for AI, given the
volume of curation that needs to happen to use AI-assisted curation to
make these processes more efficient.But also,
we're on the cusp of a dramatic change in
how we interact with these databases and
knowledge bases, and even the computer systems that we
use. So AI, large language
models are an obvious application for this type of
clinical decision support and interpretation of variants.
And in fact, a number of LLMs trained
on general medical knowledge cohorts
have been developed and released, and Med-PaLM 2 from Google
have now shown to have comparable performance as
a human on medical board exam questions.
And more recently, OpenAI has released ChatGPT Health.
I think an important component of some of these LLMs is what's called
Retrieval-Augmented Generation, or RAG, which allows an
LLM to directly link to individual citations,
whether it's clinical society guidelines or
knowledge bases like ONCOKB or the Molecular Oncology Almanac
from Elli Van Allen's group at Dana-Farber, or citing individual
papers from "New England Journal of Medicine" or "JAMA" in the medical
literature, like Open Evidence.
And a related application is in clinical trial matching,
where LLMs can retrieve individual trials, their
enrollment criteria, patient characteristics to determine who's eligible.
And a number of these, including TrialGPT, MatchMiner AI, and TrialMatch
AI, have been
developed just in the last couple of years.
And then, as you heard earlier, there are opportunities to use AI
to define patient similarity, develop digital twins,
and even pragmatic approaches like agentic AI tools for automated
tumor board summaries when,
what would have in the past involved a fellow spending an hour or
two compiling the relevant images and mutation data
and literature into a presentation, can now be done automatically and
instantly. I want to highlight here
work from Jakob Kathar's group, who just published last year an autonomous
AI agent for oncology,
integrating a lot of these methods.
This is based on GPT-4, but with additional functions and
resources like
image analysis of H&E slides, radiological image segmentation,
and web-based search functions for
PubMed, Google, and the ONCOKB knowledge base, where you can
have an interface that provides clinical context, pose a question,
and this sort of integrated method in this study was shown to have
more than double the performance accuracy as GPT-4 alone.
So this seems to be a promising direction that we're headed in,
like it or not.
And then, like I said, I want to illustrate a
few other examples where we're using AI to build
upon this precision oncology framework of detecting
mutations and determining actionability.
So one of these being cancer type diagnosis, and this is a bit of a
change of paradigm. Conventionally, molecular diagnostics is about
detecting which mutations are present and which drugs or treatments are best in
that context. Whereas histopathology would be used to determine whether
there's cancer, what type of cancer it is, what's the stage and the grade.
And just as an aside, obviously, most of you are probably aware of
advances in digital and computational pathology that can automatically
perform a lot of the tasks of a specially trained pathologist, where,
in this example from Faisal Mahmood's group at Harvard, they
developed a model for AI-assisted tumor classification, where
it can predict both the primary versus metastatic status, as well as the
tissue of origin of cancers just based on the H&E slide.
But we've done some work to try to adapt the molecular information
and use that to predict the likelihood of tumor of origin as well.
And just to briefly highlight a method that was developed by Madison Darmonfal, who
at the time was a PhD student
in my lab, also working with Quade Morris at Memorial Sloan Kettering, where she
developed a neural network trained on over 40,000 MSK-IMPACT
profiles using 5,000 genome and mutation-based
features.
Which could take advantage of this large training set of known
cancer diagnoses matched with their MSK-IMPACT profiles,
to
train and test across 38 cancer types, which accounted for over
97% of all of the cancers in our data set.
So the accuracy for all cases was about 80%, and
over 90% when you restrict to the predictions that were
associated with a high confidence score.
And rather than a black box, the feature importance could be
inferred and returned with Shapley values, and this has become a
tool that is performed in real time and
flags a case if there's a discordant prediction
from the molecular data with the surgical
pathology diagnosis. Which
when there is a difference, more often than not, of course, the diagnosis would be
accurate, but this has certainly revealed to us a number of challenging cases
where it did merit additional stains or workup, and in some cases,
identified a need to change the diagnosis.
And this is DNA-based because that's the data that we have, but potentially even
more powerful are methods using RNA signatures and DNA
methylation-based classifiers to do more or less the same
thing.
But there are interesting examples of going the opposite direction as well.
So just like we're now starting to see that the mutation
information can convey information about the cancer type, can we use the
H&E images to predict what the underlying mutations are?
And there are some interesting examples of this that have been published.
First, from Jakob Kathar's group again, inferring microsatellite
instability from the H&E images of GI cancers or predicting
IDH mutations in gliomas or EGFR mutations in lung cancer.
Still not a substitute for the actual molecular testing, but in parts of the world
that don't have easy access to next-generation sequencing, this could be a method
to screen or triage patients for those that might be carriers of clinically
relevant alterations that should be prioritized for
sequencing.And a recent example
from Kevin Bohem and colleagues at Memorial Sloan Kettering that was just
recently published in BioRxiv, took a global look across
all cancer types and mutations with the MSK Impact
data to find cancer type gene pairs where the
H&E images were very predictive of the presence of an underlying genomic
alteration.
So liquid biopsies, which I've alluded to earlier,
can be used both to detect the genomic alterations as an alternative to
tissue, but also for a wider number of potential clinical
applications. And the premise here is that
tumor cells, as they
die and turn over, can release DNA into the bloodstream that can be isolated from
plasma. And that cell-free DNA can be sequenced to
detect tumor mutations, which are often present at very low frequencies.
So the combination of the low-frequency detection
challenge as well as the broadened set of clinical
applications has offered a number of opportunities for AI.
And the clinical applications often involve different types of questions.
So not necessarily which specific mutations can we detect, but what's the
quantity of circulating tumor DNA and how does that change over time?
Or is there any tumor DNA that's detectable at all?
So this creates lots of opportunities to use new innovations in
AI to reduce the noise,
through error suppression techniques that allow us to detect mutations with
lower frequencies with higher confidence,
aggregating multiple weak signals for detecting minimal residual disease,
learning complex patterns from
the data, particularly multimodal data,
that can inform a lot of these questions.
And the challenge probably greatest for early cancer detection.
But with sequencing whole genomes of cell-free DNA,
there are many different features that one can look for and integrate as evidence
of the presence of tumor within these large data sets.
And these could include mutation patterns, copy number alterations,
fragment size profiles, methylation signatures, and we're starting to
see ML classifiers trained on thousands of samples with and without
cancer that can be used to both detect the presence of cancer
and based on the specific inputs, predict the tissue of origin.
And just one example here with an approach called fragmentomics that was pioneered
by Victor Velculescu at Johns Hopkins and has been carried forward through
Delphi.
They've developed and continue to grow fragmentomic-based methods, looking
at the fragment length distributions, where they map in the genome,
specific motifs at the ends of these fragments, and characteristics of the edges of
these fragments, as well as mutation signatures where you can,
again, use these multimodal inputs in models trained on
lots of data to identify, really trace
levels of tumor DNA in samples that may
begin to
enable early detection at the earliest stages.
And then finally, with all of these data sets that are emerging, we have the
opportunity to use this real-world evidence to develop models for better outcome
prediction. And this goes beyond just
genomic DNA. We can use pathological images, radiological images,
clinical data, and
demographics, and treatment response and outcomes.
And even the creation of these data sets, as you heard
earlier, the need to create standardized inputs to these models are
leveraging AI. And I want to highlight work by Justin Jee and Nikki Schultz at
Sloan Kettering, who have taken unstructured
radiology reports, histopathology reports, and clinical notes, applied natural
language processing to create structured clinical data elements
to complement all the genomic data that we've created through MSK Impact to create
this resource of now over 100,000 patients with very detailed,
rich, and accumulating clinical data and genomic data that can be
used for these types of models. And in their study
that was published in "Nature" just over a year ago,
they showed that when there were differences between manual curation and
NLP-derived inferred curation, about half the
time, the errors were on the manual side rather than the
automated curation.
So I think my time is up. So just to wrap up very
briefly, I've described different components of our precision oncology
workflows where AI is demonstrating an important
role. And as the number of patients who are getting ex-generation
sequencing increases and the tests themselves expand to whole
genome and transcriptome, it creates
opportunities to improve models.
It really creates a greater need for AI
to keep up with all the data that's being generated just for routine
analysis and reporting. It kind of raises the stakes of getting
this right and doing it as well as we can.
So there are a number of challenges associated with
the
scale-up of these methods and the development of models.
I guess maybe the one I want to highlight, and you heard about some of
these from Dr. Chung. The one I want to highlight, I guess is as
we train models on more and more data, to avoid model
bias, we need to make sure that the populations are
representative of the patients that we intend to
use these models on. So, I think we have a limitation at our
own center. We're only one specific geography, maybe not
representative of all
sort of national and
ancestral and ethnic groups. And it's really through
data-sharing initiatives like AACR Genie that we can grow these
larger data sets representing different
patients from different parts of the world to work towards
less biased and more interpretable models.
And also, programs like the Cancer AI Alliance or
CAIA, are pioneering federated
... learning and federated models where you can train
models and deploy across many different cancer centers, including Sloan Kettering,
including Johns Hopkins,
but without the data leaving the individual institutions.
So this is important for privacy, compliance, governance
restrictions that may
pose a challenge to the broader training and deployment of these types of models.
But I've reached the end of my time.
So I thank you for your attention, and I'm looking forward to the questions.
Thank you.
Thank you for those stimulating and very interesting talks with great visuals.
Please don't be shy. Please use the mics.
There are over 50 people online as well who are actually listening in.
So please use your mics if you have questions in the room.
While we're waiting for anyone to get up into the mic, we do
have some questions from the
Q&A tool. And the first question was around,
we know that advanced solid tumor lesions are heterogeneous within a
patient, as well as heterogeneous across patients.
Can AI models that look at patient imaging help us to get
a better measure of this intra-patient and inter-patient
heterogeneity, both at the tumor level, at the immune system level?
The questioner commented on the
fact that they recently saw an AI application to measure overall thymus
health and use this AI-generated index to predict
response to immunotherapy. I don't know if any of you wanted to tackle this
question at all.
Pass that one down.
So I guess what I would say is that
I think that it's possible for AI models to start to look at the patient
imaging and start to look at heterogeneity.
That goes back to the premise of my talk is that if you have so
much noise in your data, and you have a lot of technical
differences across these patients as well as within
patients across time, it's going to be harder for you to detect
these changes. So acknowledging what those differences
are and looking at the metadata to start to
harmonize and cross-calibrate those measurements, you'll be able
to detect these signals more likely.
And so it's going to be a combination of improving standardized
imaging as well as capturing enough metadata to be able to cross-calibrate the
imaging. There are emerging tools, such as
per-scan phantoms that you can actually scan with the
patient with absolute known values of whatever measurement you may be
interested in. And those per-scan phantoms could help you cross-calibrate.
It's like running a control with every lab assay.
And so these are sorts of tools that I think are starting to be
developed and I think will really help us in the precision medicine space.
Yes, please.
Really cool talks. I have a question about the CODA talk.
I have one short question, one long question, if that's okay.
The short question is, what is the smallest length scale at which CODA is actually
useful?
Depending on the question you're asking, of course.
But we
scan typically at 20X, so you get more or less a micron resolution,
but typically, the features become less relevant
for the kind of question we tend to ask.
But
again, the fractal dimension of blood vessels, then it's larger length
scales you'd like to integrate.
Cool. And then one of the later experiments you
showed involved T cells, and so
I was wondering-- and it didn't seem to me like there was
spatial temporal resolution to CODA. It's more of a snapshot in time, correct?
That's right. It's 3D, not 4D. Yeah.
So given the geometrical structure and
orientation of T cells in this tumor microenvironment, could
you say something about the predictability of clearance
for a cancer?
Of what?
Of clearance in a cancer. So given the organization of T cells, and I think you
also said something about gene expression, so you could maybe see the T cell types
and everything.
Can you say something about the predictability, given a snapshot image
of CODA, given some orientation of T cells about the clearance
of a tumor?
Wow.
I didn't think of that one, I have to admit.
We need to talk then. But
what's nice about CODA is that you can
mix and match. In the story with Philipp and Tu, we did
spatial metabolomics, spatial transcriptomics, spatial
proteomics, all were able to be done.
The next thing we're really doing is trying to do 3D multi-omic.
That is to train algorithm
so as to recognize those molecular features
just of H&E, like my colleague described, so that you have
true at least four micron resolution z-direction, which is
the thickness of each section, to start addressing the kind of question you're
asking. But there's a requirement here to go beyond, in this case, it was
IHC, to add on maybe epigenetics. Whatever
can be measured
spatially in 2D, we can accommodate and train our algorithm to do it in 3D,
is at least
how we think about CODA.
Cool. Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Please.
Thank you for the talks. Great session.
I wanted also to ask a question on CODA.
And I think generally, these kind of readouts and studies are the first time we
can see the tumor in so much 3D resolution, and
I was wondering what do you imagine to be essentially a new
hallmark for cancer? Because now we can look at multiple
cancers in 3D. What happens? What do you think
could be something?
So I still consider myself a novice cancer researcher, and
as such, the first thing that screamed at me
was-This
presumption I had that per volume, you'd have a higher
density in these tumors. But the
first thing that these tumors do is to kill
the healthy tissue. So actually, the number of-- the cell density of
tumors is a factor of 10 to a factor of 100 lower
than in healthy tissues, which to me was a rather remarkable
observation. And you're right,
huge diversity. One that I think hopefully came
rather readily from the talk was
immune cell infiltrates. We were,
as a demonstration of how variable immune cell infiltrates was,
taking H&E sections and ask, "Would you describe
this tumor or this lesion, in this case, as hot or cold?" And it's
really within tens of micron,
huge spatial variation in the
level immune cell infiltration and the type of immune cell infiltrations.
And so
because these
multi-omic techniques are so expensive, right?
People typically under-sample. It's 2D, and then
they're done, right? And they're all p****d off when reviewers ask for more.
But in reality,
it's all they can do, unless you bring along the Bank of England
to support your research. So what we're doing, what really
we obsess about is, again, to train our group to do all this very
expensive stuff
just from H&Es. And I can tell you, it works.
We can do now 3D
cell co,
cell neighborhoods just from H&Es, at least
10, 15 cell types based on Xenium data.
So it can be done with enough training.
Very interesting. Can I ask a follow-up?
Mm-hmm.
For the density you mentioned-
Yeah
... I'm wondering,
could you have a feeling whether it's associated also with
WHO grading? For example, the most aggressive tumor, the less dense in
the end, or it's early days for such a...
Because like for example, in the brain, we have necrosis, right?
And I guess maybe in pancreatic cancer, too.
We've done a lot less work on actual tumors and a lot-
Okay
... more work on pre-cancerous lesions. But this is a great question.
Okay.
For sure.
Okay. Thank you so much.
No, the type of metrics you can start coming up with once you
start visualizing these tumors in 3D becomes a lot more...
Enumerating cells is a 3D thing to do.
It cannot be done in 2D. And so the structure of blood
vessels, right, it's all done in 2D.
And when it's done in 3D, it's slide sheet, and then you have two or
three labels, and then you limit it.
We are, I think, able to do a lot more thanks to
Coda that way.
Okay. Thank you so much.
Yeah.
Hi.
27-year stage four cancer survivor from
Sloan Kettering, so thank you so much.
Wow, wonderful.
Wow.
And
I
remember the report I got was probably about two
pages, black and white with a couple headers,
27 years ago. Just knowing now what you've
presented, what is the patient getting now?
What does the report look like? Are they told that this was
done by AI, this was done by human? It's just so
fascinating to me.
Yeah. Thank you for sharing and for your question.
I think probably the biggest change in the reports is all of
this information
that we can-- Using the OncoKB knowledge base.
So this was not created with AI. It
involved over 100 clinical and research faculty and
fellows sort of crowdsourcing their knowledge about different genes, different
cancer types. And it follows a very
kind of regimented process. It's actually the first and only
FDA-recognized somatic knowledge base.
So that level of rigor
is a key component of the annotations that we provide.
But
we're now thinking about sequencing all 20,000 genes rather than
500 genes. So it really doesn't scale.
I think that's where we're going to need some of these AI methods to help provide
that additional information. And
in a way that
I'd be curious for you or other patients who've
received the reports, if the scientific descriptions
that sometimes are a little too technical
are useful. So, I think some of the large language
models have the opportunity to convey information in a more digestible
format. So I think there are a lot of advantages to what's coming.
But because of patients who've
been treated and who've been part of our program,
we've generated so much data that the ability to use that coupled with
outcomes to learn which of these features that we might not have recognized as
important in the past can now indicate who might benefit from a treatment
that may not have even existed at the time,
is where I think a lot of the new scientific and clinical value have
come. I'm happy to talk more if you have any more questions.
Just a follow-up from a cybersecurity point of view.
Is the data getting scrubbed and is in a closed system?
I'm an advocate and an expert in AI from the
healthcare perspective, but not from your side, just from
the patient side. And I'm just curious what's being done in
terms of security. I know we're not practicing it as
patients. We're putting all our stuff in an unscrubbed, and it's just
going to train. But how are you guys protecting everything?
Yeah. I'm probably not the best person to speak to
that. We have a very large and active
data security team. You might have your own perspectives from your role at MD
Anderson. We
actually put a lot of work, because data sharing has been so important, even just
internally among our 20-plus thousand employees.
We put a lot of work into making data available, but with all
PH, protected health information, and identifiers removed.
So we have our raw sequencing data sitting in our clinical
HPC cluster. We have a replica without any identifiers available
to researchers. Both are heavily secured and controlled for
the-For the raw data itself. But the
benefits of making those data available in a de-identified form to
researchers has been tremendous through the ability to bring new
algorithms and methods into practice clinically.
Just like our testing is in a highly regulated environment, we can't run a test on
a patient sample and report it back to their doctor or themselves
unless it's in this highly clinically regulated environment.
Every test that we perform, every analysis that we do, has to go through that path.
But we can do other investigations using the de-identified data that
we can then put through that path as well.
So that's another reason why a patient's test today might have a lot more
information than it might have 15 years ago.
I don't know if you want to comment.
Use ChatGPT, huh? Get your report and then you can maybe-
That's what I'm trying to stop patients from doing.
Yes.
They don't understand.
Yes, this is true. And I think this is true for all researchers as well.
Please don't put your genomic sequences into public
instances of ChatGPT. That's going right up into the cloud.
So, just be mindful of what you are doing.
Many institutions now have enterprise
tools that you can actually use, and whichever tools you may have at your
institution, those enterprise tools are the ones that are secure.
I think your question is interesting in that
as we start to embrace more and more of the complexity, so now you have the
genomics plus all your treatment information.
Even if you say you're going to de-identify, when you start to create
the constellation of events and you have your somatic
genomics, and you have your tumor genomics,
the identifiability risk is going up.
And I think we just have to all acknowledge that.
And so I think that the traditional protected health
information requirements are no longer addressing
the kind of data that we are actually dealing with.
HIPAA is a little outdated-
Yes
... in the form that we sign. And just one thing to the people here.
Tomorrow, we're doing a session on AI for the
researcher, but it's more about telling your story,
not in terms of classified information.
It's more about how to tell your story to the media and funders, and
that's at 8:00 tomorrow morning.
That's great. Thank you.
Thanks a lot for the...
This is for Dr. Berger. So thanks for the detailed
use cases for AI. My question is that there were some great
publications, great work that has happened.
When and how do you think it can be moved to a clinician?
Because there will be a lot of worries by clinicians to implement these
AIs for their day-to-day usage, because in the end, it's affecting the
patient. So what should be someone creating a product
for a clinical decision think of for
it to be used by the clinicians?
I'm sorry. Some of the echo made it hard for me to understand some parts of your
question. Was it about what tools specifically geared
towards clinicians?
No. How do we ensure that the tools that are being made
are accepted by the clinicians?
Accepted by clinicians. Okay. So clinician buy-in.
That's a really interesting question, and I've observed just
from the clinicians that I'm interacting with,
the full range.
Some are more
gung ho about the opportunity and the new tools that are available than
anyone in my lab.
But others are very concerned about moving forward with the
possibility of misinterpretation or hallucinations.
So I don't know that I...
I don't know if you cover scientists or if more engineer, but
work with clinicians. I think from the very beginning, not at the end
to test them and then
as an afterthought. I would really
recommend if you're designing AI tools to involve clinicians
from the beginning. We met monthly with Ralph and Laura
exactly as to avoid the
problem that too many bioengineers develop solutions for problems that don't exist,
you know?
Exactly. Yes. So, I think that you want to ask more than one
clinician, because often what I see in terms of many startups that
happen, they've found one passionate physician that's going to say, "This is
the problem that needs to get solved." They spend time and money to actually build
this tool out, and then you go and show it to five other clinicians, and they're
like, "I don't know why you're doing this." Right?
So I think that really ask around and make sure that the
question that you're trying to address is really meaningful.
And then going back to what I was highlighting is you have to think about
what is the readily available data, because someone might be excited about
it, but if they can't use it at their center because that data is not generated,
it's not a useful tool. And so I think you need to think about that piece.
And the final piece is that I think
this is getting better, but clinicians will start to
trust it if you're probably a bit more transparent about what that uncertainty
is. And so,
the early tools really gave an answer, and
you either trusted the answer or you didn't.
But if you gave a confidence interval around it and say, "This is sort of the
range," I think that helps people start to understand what
this tool actually represents. How do you integrate it into your
decision-making depends on what that range of uncertainty really
is. And so I would-
Thank you. Thanks.